kind of cold in here by the way it's
freezing because how often do you see me
wearing a sweater I'm wearing sweaters
my nipples meanwhile you're out here
chest out abs are you not chilly
whatsoever you know how are you sweating
right now I've always been like this you
know like I've always been like this in
my 20s and my 30s I don't know what it
is you know but uh the the benefit is
when it's really cold outside I usually
do pretty good we're chilling but any
other time you know like I asked my guys
is there any way you can get in touch
with them is there any way you can ask
him to lower the AC just a little bit we
did we're all paying the price by the
way when's the last time you were sure I
was just gonna ask that yeah like like
somebody's like behind wedding are you
just like I'll wear a bow tie I'm not
wearing no sure you know normally it's
just um really sorry can't come to your
wedding oh really you know because
they're like brother you know I I
haven't had to figure that out yet um I
don't wear shirt very often I gotcha you
know and and by the way this was a thing
way before social media I didn't wear a
shirt yeah and and so a lot of people
say hey why don't you wear a shirt
there's a lot of reasons why I don't
wear a shirt you know I mean part of it
is when I explain you know the Primal
raw first version itself you're
undomesticated self
um you know show me how you look bare
chested you know reveal to me you want
to go right now brother
your philosophies your principles let's
have a conversation you know um
obviously how we look bare chest it
doesn't say everything about us but it
says something right about us and I
didn't wear a shirt before social and so
I decided I'm not putting on a shirt
after social you know a lot of people
actually through all this stuff
happening
um try to say hey here's what here's how
you should say your apology and you
should put a shirt on nah you're like no
way I'll do the apology bro there's no
shirt that's coming on here so Brian how
hard is this like going out or like
going to like a restaurant or something
like do you deal with that or do they
recognize you and they're like yo it's a
liver King get on the goddamn table no I
assume you put a shirt on when you go to
a restaurant it's pretty nice I don't he
doesn't he says he's in Texas Texas but
you know what straight up we we make a
video of it and there's like a five-star
restaurant people are wearing suits and
ties it's all nice and and you have me
dropping down at the dinner table doing
Max effort push-ups my simulated hunt
before I eat looking like a caveman I
love it you know and and so then we we
make a small video out of it and and so
thank God you know I have a great team
that calls ahead of time and says hey
here's what's going to happen you know
if there's if there's not a private room
you know yeah they disagree so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of by you taming
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]